[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissing
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of watching people argue on the
internet about subjects they know
nothing about trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts we ask the
experts
our amazing guest this week is a
controversial youtube star with nearly a
million subscribers sargon of akkad
Carl Benjamin welcome to chicken on
check thanks I really appreciate it
[Music]
we're really really appreciate you
coming on the show thank you so much
before we get started if anyone who
doesn't know who you are which is not
many people these days so you've been
all over the shop in the media and
elsewhere who are you what do you do and
how did you come to the place that you
are at now well I'm certainly not an
expert
that's interview over basically I I kept
seeing I I wasn't really engaged in my
20s and I you know I was just coasting
through my life just working in regular
jobs just as tech admins and things like
this and I would continually listen to
audiobooks in my in my hair while I was
doing and by the time I came to my early
30s I realized that the world was not
being run as I approved of it was
becoming remarkably illiberal
in many different ways and I just found
it it was getting to the point where I
was like why is no one pointing this out
you know what surely everyone can see
that we shouldn't be making like racial
distinctions on hiring for the BBC or
things like this you know which is
something they actually do and so I just
started making videos about things that
were concerning me and I was an absolute
fool because I never really thought it
was gonna go anywhere I just I just had
to get it off my chest and so I had a
youtube account that was just registered
under my gamertag which is serving a
week out you know when I was playing
video games and now I'm stuck with the
name I wish I'd use my own name you know
but some and so yeah I'm basically I
just got to work just researching so
what what the hell's going on five years
later I'm like wow we've got real
problems and they and they started this
almost fundamental philosophical level
and we need to have a conversation about
the the just the the principles that we
base our decisions on because if you
think about like what's happening look
look at the young the Carrie Gracie
decision at the moment with the BBC I
don't know whether you guys been
following you but she's recently
nationally at 280,000 pounds out of the
BBC licence payer because she didn't get
paid the same as a man who worked twice
as many hours as her in a more stressful
job and so she's there saying well it's
about the principle of equality it's
like okay well that's not a principle I
agree - I agree to the principle if you
get what you earn and if you work four
hours a day on a relatively easy job in
China
reading the news for files then you're
on on a flight to hours or something
a week then a guy who's on I had twice
as much as you and works in a
high-stress job like in Washington DC he
deserves more money than you there's
just no getting around it the jobs
aren't the same it's not comparable
and so like we need to get down to these
sort of basic axioms of how we even form
our political beliefs because when we
get there you realize that liberal
philosophy has essentially been
subverted by continental collectivism
and this is a problem especially if
you're an English liberal like myself
you're an individualist you you believe
in the the agency of the individual you
come to see I mean I think we've got a
women and equalities branch of the
government at this point I mean that
sounds like something that I would
expect to see in the Soviet Union you
know I do that's it's not the
government's job to make us equal it's
the government's job to protect our
rights and that's it and so that's what
I'm more interested in return sort of
more traditional English British liberal
sort of like governmental structure I
know it's a massive undertaking that I'm
proposing but I'm I mean it's it's
really got to the point where there
there's just such a chasm between these
two styles of belief that we we have to
address it I was gonna ask why for the
benefit of anyone doesn't know who you
are why you're controversial but I think
we'll address that all right honestly
the controversy isn't from any of my
beliefs I I mean I I know I mean I'm
anti-racist I'm an anti-fascist I'm
anti-communist and I think the problem
is that after after World War two
right-wing socialism fascism Nazism was
absolutely discredited there was there
was no no future for a hat so I got
completely wiping map but I didn't
happen with left wing left wing
socialism the Soviet Union it took a
long time for the says you need to
collapse and so many actors is in
incredibly intellectual people on the
Left we're basically using this to fuel
their desire to implement socialism and
obviously that's failed everywhere has
been tried and so now liberalism is the
only ideology left standing
and so when I'm saying that I'm for what
classical British liberalism and they're
saying well you're a fascist I'm just
saying you don't know what liberalism or
fascism is then you know you don't know
about the terms I'm talking about and
I'm I'm part of the intellectual
tradition that was first into the field
against fascism
and the fascist if you read like
Mussolini's doctrine of fascism he rails
against liberalism all day in the same
way that Hitler did in mine camp they
can't stand it I mean they think it's a
Jewish invention and things like this is
it's just like it's like well we can't
have a conversation then can we you know
if you're gonna call me a Nazi and I'm
gonna call you a commie then I guess we
have to go to war and nobody is
representing each other's beliefs
accurately so you were talking as well
about diversity and do you not think
that actually in terms of the BBC we
need diversity quotas to reflect the
fact that our society more and more is
becoming more multicultural it shouldn't
just be for instance white males
particularly white males from Oxford see
isn't that a white supremacist opinion
I'm not joking why why in a meritocratic
system couldn't a non-white person apply
for a job be the best for the job and
get the job why could they not do this
it mean do we think that the BBC is run
by racists I think the the
counter-argument to that is ultimately
we we surround ourselves with people who
we inadvertently who we know who we're
most comfortable with and if you are
like a white boy can grow up in a part
of South London like me you end up
socialising with white people mainly
from South London or you feel more
comfortable dealing with people from
your part of the world essentially I
think people are more comfortable
dealing with people who think like them
and so I don't think that your race is
very important when that conversation
comes around I mean you you get a lot of
people who are young the the children of
migrants who came in the 60s or 70s and
they were very left-wing very
progressive I don't think that they're
being held back because of their race or
anything like that I think that then
that I think that the fact that they
believe the same sorts of things as what
the people at the BBC and running the
BBC believe is a natural advantage them
I mean I don't think the BBC would ever
hire me not because I'm white or maybe
because I might actually actually do
have quotas against white people in the
BBC but primarily because I do not
subscribe to socialism and my entire
worldview is informed by that and their
entire worldview is informed by their
socialism home date they would just find
themselves on a fundamental disagreement
Lee so if we were to sit in an interview
they would they would probably not
necessarily know why they disagreed but
like no he's he doesn't give me the
right feeling because I'm not confirming
what they want to hear whereas someone
you know a South Asian person who came
in and said y'all I think progressivism
is great they they would be absolutely
oh that was I was a great person I don't
think this country is run by white
supremacists and racists I think this
country is in fact pathologically
anti-racist to the point where we've got
to the point where just the allegation
is enough to ruin someone's career it's
like but you you can't really prove
unless they're demonstrably doing
something you know unless they're openly
wandering around Zig heiling is it's
really difficult to prove someone's a
racist you know and this is this is the
problem the allegation itself it only
has white because you care whether
you're a racist or not if you were a
racist you wouldn't care of someone
cause you're a racist you're like and
you know you wouldn't take action but
suddenly will oh god we need diversity
we better do everything we can to make
sure we're not racist like if you're
doing that you're probably not a racist
a racist we can give it them they'll
probably be proud of it if any of the
viewers are wondering why I've been
smiling through this whole exchanges I'm
just waiting for you destroy this the
thing that I mean that that question
comes from a completely different set of
presuppositions than my answer and I
mean what what's your answer you said
well that's true we're not racists you
know we don't need to I mean I I find it
I find there's something deeply
concerning about a focus on race I mean
there are so many other more more
salient characteristics when talking
about person and these are you know
these are usually within the agency of
the person the person is choosing their
own beliefs and that's another question
whether you actually choose your beliefs
are but the the the the roots of your
beliefs and like the the the way you
form your worldview in the way you
interact with other people I really
think that race plays a much smaller
role at least in this country than it
does and other countries I mean in
America it's a much more like prescient
and to the fourth issue which it's very
annoying talking to Americans about like
class they can't differentiate class
from race but in this country I think
class is a much bigger barrier
I mean if I came in here with a very low
class accent I do
Bichette in AB C's there's a huge amount
of middle-class condescension to the
working classes and we see this in the
term gamin I mean it feels like a racist
term doesn't it
Oh is there a sister yo well you're
talking about a group of people based on
their skin color and you're making
aspersions insertion is a power auger
tree yeah yeah exactly it's used as a
Federation of erasers well I mean they
would they would sit there and do some
mental gymnastics to tell you that it's
not racist but it at least at the very
least they can concede that it feels
like a racist term um yeah if you'd made
up like a coffee bean or something for a
brown person you know they would say oh
that's racist so you know I mean because
you're wearing a jacket in this funny
thing we don't have banter in Russia so
I'm always I never quite understand
where the line is between being actually
rude and just played playfully insulting
someone I know because in Russia once
you go over a certain line yeah is it
nice enough you can be honest I'll be
polite you're not the first guest who's
complained we had Liam Halligan on who's
a pro brexit economy and commentator and
he spent about three minutes ripping
into me about the quality of the tea
well on the show I mean he's not wrong
all right well there we go this is how
British people use particularly English
people from the South say that that tear
[ __ ] yeah I'm gonna be polite
we'll make you a proper cup of tea or
Francis will anyway
yeah I'll make a proper cup of
Venezuelan company yeah all right well
anyway um well what I was gonna ask you
you've been very successful with your
YouTube channel you've like I said you
approaching
rapidly million subscribers and I think
that tells you quite a lot about what's
happening in society I agree and one of
the things I find very interesting about
your videos is you started out you
didn't even show your face it was just
text and you would comment on things and
so you've essentially in this world now
that's obsessed with how things look
you've actually gone for the content yes
and that content has attracted people
who are like-minded who are interested
in what you're talking about what do you
think that tells you what do you think
your success tells us about the society
of today and the problems that we face I
think that political correctness is a
kind of weapon that's used to silence
and marginalize people who are who us
who are voting citizens who have a
legitimate cause to a legitimate right
to participate and democracy as the same
as anyone else but because it falls
outside of the the acceptable range of
discussion then these subpoenas are
silenced but that doesn't mean they go
away that just means they fester in the
darkest corners of the Internet and so
when I start talking about things that
need to be spoken about but aren't
politically incorrect then I'm
considered some sort of renegade or
rebel even though I actually am pretty
damn mainstream in my opinions really
I'm just prepared to deal with the tough
issues that nobody else really wants to
talk about because they're afraid of
being called names and so what are the
tough issues that you tackle for anyone
who doesn't watch your channel yeah I
mean I think feminism is a major one but
that's just an outgrowth of I guess what
you would call intersectionality it's a
it's a kind of postmodern philosophy
that's essentially become hegemonic over
the left you'll notice that liberals now
just considers be right-wing I mean I
always considered myself center-left
whenever I do political compass test I'm
always on the center-left libertarian
spectrum and I get told relentlessly
than I'm right-wing and so essentially I
mean intersectionality is essentially
the combination of all the philosophies
that play on identity politics which is
essentially the politics of victimhood
and so you've got socialism you've got
sort of black lives matter cell racial
politics you've got feminism all of
these suddenly because they operate
along the same line
they can all be bundled into the same
package which is intersectionality and
this is why they now have a racial and
gender hierarchy of oppression called
the progressive stack I mean I'm
suddenly thinking that's the most
horrific thing I've ever seen to
categorize people's privilege based on
their race and gender I mean it's it's
so unbelievable and dehumanizing in my
opinion and you'll kneel nursing the way
they took use the term like female
bodies black bodies white bodies they'll
use these terms and I'm like that's how
I would describe corpses you know I
would never describe a living human
being as just a body that's the most
dehumanizing thing I've ever heard and
yet this is standard academic language
it's disgraceful in my opinion and so
this has made me a complete renegade and
no one wanted to talk about it in this
way because I guess the Liberals have
just lost their spine they've lost all
their moral courage and I don't know why
because liberalism is the only ideology
with any repute left which is why the
left still hides behind the term liberal
but as soon as you start saying well I'm
in favor of capitalism which it's called
a liberal principle all the sudden it's
like oh you're a right winger say
absolutely not I'm in favor of people
having food on the table and I'm hurting
money in their pocket and on a TV and
you know you know spare time I'm not in
favor of them going hungry you know and
so it's it's basically I think it was
just because I was addressing things
that the mainstream would not touch or
didn't know how to touch I think there's
kind of groupthink that traps them all
and there's there's definitely kind of
cult-like behavior of demonizing the
outsider and denouncing people who would
be dissidents you know it's typical cult
behaviors and I think people fall into
these patterns of behavior without
realizing it and I think it's remain
healthy do you not think no that was
something like feminism at its core it's
it's still needed especially when you
look at what's happening in the world
we're in a lot of countries women simply
aren't equal women don't have the right
to vote issues like FGM are still
happening they still happen in this city
in London I mean when I was a teacher I
used to see you know gobs you know
literally disappeared for months on end
and then come back no questions asked
the black lives matter movement I mean
you would say it's incredibly relevant
especially in America well unfortunate
in America in America again
it's a class pumper in England in
Britain it's it's actually is actually
the opposite happens in this country if
you look at like black and monarch
minority ethnic deaths in police custody
they're actually underrepresented in
this country it's 13 percent of the
population is non-white and only 10
percent of the deaths in police custody
are non-white and so if anything you
would it by that logic you would need a
white lives matter movement in Britain
because it's disproportionately the
white working-class that dying in police
custody in this country and so you can't
just import an American idea over to
here because the context is different
and then with regards to feminism the
problem that you have is what's kind of
feminism the intersectional feminists
have and it's only been in the last like
three or four years I've watched this
happen I mean when I first started
people like Germaine Greer were credible
feminists Germaine Greer now is being
deployed for now I found this because
intersectionality is steamrolled the
feminist movement and what it's done
it's been very clever it's it's all
about language games about labeling and
so if you're not an intersectional
feminist then you are a white feminist
and if you are a race activist being
white is a negative thing because you're
perceived as the oppressor I mean the
question you have to ask yourself in
regardless are you were pressing women
because you're a man may know I'm very
much second in the relationship my
girlfriend is a professor of psychology
there's not a feminist so she's the one
in charge it's all predicated on the
idea that men are oppressing women and
if you don't think men are oppressing
women in Britain then you can't really
be a feminist or at least an
intersectional feminist you call
yourself a liberal feminist and I mean
if there was a strong liberal feminist
movement I would call myself a liberal
feminist because I'm I'm totally in
favor of women having the exact same
rights as men you know I can't see any
justification for women not having the
same rights I mean I I would rather the
laws be written without reference to man
or woman and saying citizens have these
rights you know I mean I might never
need an abortion but on the off chance
that I do need an abortion somehow I
can't actually get one because abortions
are only for women and so I mean what if
I was a man who did need an abortion I
couldn't get one you know and I don't
see why the law should distinguish in
that way but that's not only the
feminist movement of today wants to do
but I mean I totally agree there's like
I mean Saudi Arabia is the easy go-to
country to say
then you know they've only just been
given the permission to drive they still
can't leave the country without male
guardian you know I mean obviously
that's I mean but but again I mean you
don't necessarily need feminism that I
mean if you were to go over there with
liberal principles you would be able to
make arguments from liberalism for
women's rights I mean there's a reason
that in this country we gave women the
vote in 1918 I think it was like nine
years after the men got a vote
whereas in France and Germany it was in
the 50s I think you know we've always
been ahead of the curve when it comes to
human rights and it's but it's because
of the sort of British liberal
principles that our society has spent a
thousand years building up and crafting
to this point in England like it the
English don't like to say this but
England is an unbelievably exceptional
place when it comes to moral perfection
and there is there are so many other
places that just we listen to them
because we hold ourselves to account and
we don't have the sort of courage in our
own traditions anymore it really is this
pointing and it's turning country into
something that it shouldn't be we had a
better country before we started
adopting these things in my opinion and
I mean a better country for people who
aren't just white males I mean you know
for for women for minorities for for all
these people you know we don't need to
have the kind of authoritarian top-down
system that they are trying to implement
we can solve the problem from the bottom
up that's my thing do you think it's
creating a culture of fear where people
are afraid that if they disagree with
somebody's point of view that they're
going to be labelled as you know racist
whatever else and essentially I mean you
see it sometimes in extreme cases where
people end up losing their jobs careers
getting publicly shamed yeah
unit you already know the answer you
know that there's a culture of everyone
knows of the culture of fear and this is
what we found on the rothermund report
when it came to the creaming gangs the
police the councilmembers they were all
afraid of being labeled racist and so in
the pursuit of not being labeled as
racists they would ignore the
20-something Pakistani men who are doing
the grooming and treat the young
vulnerable white girls a 12 year old 13
year old girls as if they were
prostitutes I mean if that's not a
miscarriage of justice because of
political correctness I don't know what
is and I can't see how anyone can
justify that and then the MP who tried
to speak out about it for rather um she
got fired from her labor job because she
spoke
because labor have bought into all of
the social justice activism hmm you know
I mean it's it's absolutely catastrophic
and I think that's one of the reasons
for my rise you know my success is
because I'm prepared to in a principled
way address these things you know rather
than rather than rather than I mean
they're on the internet there are loads
of like neo-nazi LARPers and they're
just sorry to interrupt what so I don't
know what's an OP oh it sounds like like
some kind of exotic animal you see
someone who's basically pretending to be
this to be to be edgy and counterculture
but is so of a Milo you're not police
almost kind of figure no I mean yes but
for neo-nazis America Milo's not a Nazi
Milan - at a classical liberal as well
but some they like to do it for the
shock value okay but really I don't
think they hold any of these beliefs but
they like to make it look like they do
because then you all you're offended
yeah you know but it's it requires
someone principled to speak out about
these things I think and I think that's
one of the reasons for my success
[Music]
well one of the things that you really
talk about a lot is free speech right
and we had Brendan O'Neill who you know
when you're a fan of the phone on the
show a few weeks ago and he was talking
about free speech and we were trying to
get from him like examples count thank
you low side right of people who are
whose speech is being restricted in this
country in Britain right and he came he
told us about some woman who does
Holocaust denial songs and all this kind
of stuff and as principled as a person
as I tried to be I kind of look at those
people and I go well I'm not sure I can
get behind defending your right to do
Holocaust denial songs you know what I
mean and beyond that is there really a
free speech problem in Britain without
doubt I mean why shouldn't she have the
right to deny the Holocaust I mean that
yeah this is where we get into the
principle versatility because
practicality would say well she's
contributing to to a narrative that
didn't happen and there's going to be
people who then believe that it's the
most trouble of the Holocaust did happen
we've got an overwhelming amount of
evidence that shows I mean we've got the
inner peace of the camps the bodies you
know we've got the Nazi literature that
shows us why they hated the Jews and
what they were gonna do to them we can
plot a direct course people denying the
Holocaust are just denying an aspect of
reality so let them I mean it's not
illegal to deny the Holocaust Alice
qunari
you know she should be right to say I
mean you are then free to use your free
speech to make her look silly and you
should you know you you definitely have
a moral duty to make these people look
ridiculous but I I can't find any
justification for the government to
restrict your free speech I mean is
terrible and the things it gets worse I
mean like if you look at article 1 to 7
we've criminalized offense
that's unbelievable I mean how can they
suggest that I shouldn't be free to
offend someone that's I mean what by
what right are they claiming that I must
be restricted in my ability to offend
people how am i free if I'm not free to
offend you then i how am i free you know
and this is this is causing thousands of
people a year to be arrested over social
media posts and i'm absolutely done with
it i want the absolute repeal of the
article her section one to seven because
i don't think people should be arrested
over an offensive social media post it's
up to you the city
to deal with that person to dis children
why you think they're wrong to argue
with them to mock them to treat them how
if you want but it's not up to the
government sit there and arrest you for
say something on Twitter it's ridiculous
but I mean the problem is is in the line
start to get blurred I mean where do you
so do you see it an incitement to
violence is that your right of freedom
of speech I I personally am a free
speech absolutist so I think any action
you take is on you but I'm more than
willing to compromise on assignment
things like incitement libel slander I
can accept this because your public
character matters and you're not always
in the same position to be able to
defend yourself so I can understand
legal recourse being taken if someone's
calling you a pedophile on the BBC or
something and you know you're obviously
not then yes you should be able to take
public you know legal action against
that person or if you're if you're I'm
speaking as a person who stood in front
of a crowd of 10,000 people and spoken I
can understand how in an environment
like that incitement can be a thing you
know and you do have a measure of power
over a group of people that you wouldn't
normally have in everyday life and so
yes you probably do have to be more
responsible in circumstances like that
but just saying something racist or
saying something inflammatory offensive
I don't agree that they should be
criminalized but then so you took the
example of you delivering your speech to
10,000 people but isn't it the same the
fact that how many subscribers do you
have to your YouTube channel eight
hundred and fifteen thousand so every
time you put a video out you send it to
eight hundred and fifteen thousand do
you not therefore have a responsibility
to those eight hundred and fifteen
thousand to not say something that could
then be an incitement to violence for
people to I think it depends on the
context I mean if there were eight
hundred thousand people watching my
video in an auditorium or a stadium or
something then sure because the
environment matters you know when you
surrounded by like many people and if
people in that bedrooms are on their
office or something watching something I
don't think it's the same it's you get
an atmosphere and energy you know that
happens and now that's how I think the
the restriction with something to
violence is justified but no I mean I
think people should be free to say these
things but we then have a responsibility
as citizens to address these things on a
social level but that's and this is this
is a remarkably like I I guess I would
call an English attitude the idea that
it's up to us it's not up to the
government
hold one another accountable and it's
got to the point though I mean and again
this is I think the way that political
correctness has taken advantage of us by
denying us these basic rights I mean for
example the ability to offend is how
different groups of people negotiate
what is an acceptable way to deal with
one another and this is manifested most
quintessentially British British Lee in
Banta something you were saying that you
didn't understand yes banter Wreckers in
Russia didn't have it but in this
country I don't think we could live
without it especially I mean we've had
these four constituent nations that have
been side by side and warring with one
another for a thousand years I mean
there's got to manifest itself in a way
that we can we can recognize and
normalize the differences between us
without hating one another and that's
that I mean like I love the fact that in
Scotland when it comes to the World Cup
they pouch for shirts that say anyone
but England it's so funny to me you know
I mean you know you could portray not as
racist it's actually more than that card
because I lived in Scotland for many
years and it's not anyone you know their
favourite country and everywhere cup is
Argentina that's because they beat us
all not only because they beat Italy
because they'd be you by cheating that's
why but when he came to the independence
vote what country votes to remain in a
union you know do you think the
Catalonians and vote to remain in in
Spain absolutely not they were denied
their vote to leave Spain but the Scots
chose to stay and that's that tells you
something about the tolerance and
plurality of Britain they don't feel
that they're being unjustly held in here
and could have a referendum to leave
actually will stay thank you very much
okay you know it can't be bad so there
have been times on the internet where
people have linked you with the author
in particular the Guardian opposes
posted an article about it they've also
been other other websites would why did
is it that people say that you're all
right and what is your response okay I
think um I mean the most basic level
they do it because there's a strategy
what they they know that when I come to
talk to you about these issues I'm going
to approach another way they can't
reason
deal with because I'm gonna make them
seem like authoritarians and I make them
seem tyrannical because frankly that's
my opinion of them I do think they are a
tyrannical and so what they're trying to
do is put an idea in your mind that oh
this guys are Nancy because they aren't
right for anyone who doesn't know the
alt-right are essentially just white
nationalists
they want a state with whites only
people I'm mixed-race my dad is half
white half West Indian you know so I you
know I grew up on the feet of my
grandfather told me play chess and he's
a very dark-skinned man from the West
Indies I don't want a white people only
stake so I don't want my father to be
kicked out of my country you know my
father is as English as it comes he's a
military man you know he's is very
British and I think it would be I mean I
think the idea of like a like racial
discrimination that would be a
catastrophe and I mean Britain's always
had a very multi-ethnic early Britain
itself as a multi-ethnic state you know
the the corniche the English the Scots
the eres the Welsh they don't all
consider themselves one race and then
you've got the British Empire if it
seeks the Gurkhas and the the Pakistanis
you know you who have relations to the
identity that is British that isn't
based on races it's based on other
things and so when the alt-right come
along so right we're we're essentially I
mean I don't want to just call you Nazis
because that's always uses an easy way
of dismissing someone's ideas but they
very much agree with Adolf Hitler on the
idea of a racial super state you know
they think that white people should be
in a unique state with themselves and
have no interaction with normally States
and I'm just like that's the furthest
thing from what I believe and I mean
being a liberal I'm an individualist I
think that all individuals should be
treated equally by the state without
exception their racial collectivists and
so they are they are naturally opposed
to what I believe just fundamentally
they they can't agree with anything that
I say on that basis I mean you'll get
those clips of Richard Spencer one of
the most popular people in the alt-right
saying they use just openly against free
speech I mean I'm a free speech
fundamentalist I mean always described
by the mirror as a free speech extremist
I proudly wear that label yeah you know
I'm very much free speech tours is it's
the complete polar opposite of what the
honorary months
but because the alt-right also operates
in the kind of dissident online space
there are much smaller presence I mean
they they give
a lot more weight than they deserved
that if there are 50 thousands of them
worldwide I'll be amazed I don't think
there are that many at all but the
reason they say I'm alt-right linked is
because I debate against them I've
debated against Richard Spencer Jared
Taylor not only was a bunch of a bunch
of other lie American online ones that
people weren't recognized you know but
some but I've debated against all the
major names you know and told them that
I think you're wrong I just think you're
council directly wrong the things you're
saying and I don't think the what you're
saying has philosophical consistency and
I don't think as moral consistency and
so when they say I mean Russia today
outright called me all right and I think
I might have a case to sue them because
it's obviously a defamatory way of just
essentially calling me a Nazi and if you
can somehow get fascism from what I'm
saying then you don't understand what
I'm saying that's my opinion
do you not think sorry France did you
don't think that a big part of the
reasons that people can get away with
saying that you're all right linked or
whatever is that free speech has become
so associated with the right where I
wing politics in this country and
elsewhere yeah it's it's crazy I mean
you're right like I said earlier that
they're not in favor of free speech they
don't want that because free speech
means that Jewish people can say things
and they can't have Jewish people saying
things because they have really negative
opinions about Jews and they think that
Jewish people are only like
stereotypically they think they're
sneaky and evil and it's like like I've
got a list of Jewish friends who are
clearly not sneaky and evil so just stop
saying it but you know they're not in
favor of that so I mean the idea that
the left has given up on free speech is
an indication that the in section
allottee and essentially socialism is
taking it over you can't be on the left
anymore you cannot socialist those
socialist regimes aren't a favor of free
speech either because they're
collectivist you know they won't they
won't curated speech their own speech
you can say party propaganda but you
can't say something dissenting the
dissenters have to be silenced so moving
on a little bit then in terms of
socialism and party politics you've
recently joined you kid I have you have
and I initially read that it was more of
a trolling moved by you you were just
having fun campaign killer put some
stuff on his Twitter saying if enough
people retweet this we all join have you
joined on that basis or is there some
kind of
the reason that you're actually there
there's more of a principle reason I
mean like it's it's always funny to get
their panties in a bunch because they
they I don't know why they call you kept
far right you kept as a classical
liberal party it's a very British party
you know I mean I've spoken to Jared
batter and I've spoken to many of the
members right now and I mean they they
they have a section on the website when
you get to sign up saying look if you've
ever been a member of the BNP the EDL
you know any of the sort of like fascist
parties you just can't join them but the
argument there would be as a counter
argument would be that they need to do
that because they have lots of people
like that who would join the party
because it's a right-wing party well I
mean maybe you know there are X BMP
people in labor at the moment so you
know you it's I don't I don't think you
should define yourself by what the
racists do you define yourself by your
own principles and if you if I mean like
I I'm I wouldn't call myself a
nationalist but I'm Pro the nation-state
I think the nation-state is a useful
thing to exist I think it's good for the
people that live under it and and so if
I'm in favor of the nation-state I'm not
in favor of the European Union I'm not
in favor of breaking down national
borders I think that causes more
problems than it solves and so a
neo-nazi would say well I'm a I'm an
obviously a nationalist as a neo-nazi
therefore if he's a nationalist I would
rather join him than labour other
conservatives because they both seem to
be fun borders and so they they're just
doing it for political expediency not
because of consistency of opinion or
ideological conformity but it's you know
you just got to keep these people out
because we don't agree and ultimately
they would be the enemy if they had any
political power the problem we have of
them is the left has absolute hegemony
over the dialogue which is why some
Lemire a reasonable radical centrist is
is someone controversial I was gonna say
so you've joined you kit now my question
always review kippis what's the point of
view cube there were one policy party
they achieved their own they got brexit
so what's the point they were of one
policy party they're not anymore I think
that you Kipp is basically going to
become the home of people who are tired
of political correctness when it comes
to the point because I think one of the
problem that most people have with
political correctness is the unearned
moral superiority the people who claim
to be promoting it
claim and they treat you as such they
treat you as a thing they are your moral
betters and when you are finally sick
and tired of being spoken to like an
aunt then just say right okay I'm just
going to join you kid and you watch them
recoil in horror about how could you do
this well because you're the way you
speak me that's why I'm not gonna be
spoken to like that I'm gonna take
political action against you and it's
gonna be through you Kip because you can
actually do stand for traditional
British values they actually stand for
anti-authoritarianism so I am or
decentralization of power free speech
you know free thought they actually do
stand for these things traditional
British values that we've stir we used
to project around the world and people
would look up to we're ashamed of now
it's tragic and yeah I'm Dameron for you
Kip and I think that if you're if you're
sick of this crap then it's time for us
to stop it one of the issues the taint
that I think you keep was this link
between brexit and xenophobia this idea
that anyone who votes for brexit is
racist and by the way both the Francis
and I voted remain but because good
people know he's very good but as an
immigrant in this country myself I was
incredibly frustrated the the argument
against vote voting leaf was essentially
that anyone who votes leave was racist
because as you said earlier I think this
is one of the most fundamentally
progressive open welcoming tolerant
countries in the world in the history of
the world so the idea that half of the
borough's public voted to leave the EU
because they're racist I think is
insulting absolutely but I do think
there were other things that did happen
during a campaign like nice offer are
standing in front of that poster of my
own from whatever that you can became
tainted is what is is what I'm driving
on right in in the in the left-wing
imagination certainly I mean and then
from the conservative point of view
they've got no reason to try and
counteract their narrative because you
kept a direct threat to their services
so why wouldn't they just go along with
that yo yeah there are they're racist
they could Xena folks but you can
actually just look at the reason the
people were voting for brexit it was
never about xenophobia or race or
economic and in the north of England are
suffering under mass immigration that no
one would deny this even even the
Guardian writes articles explained all
year long you know maybe there's a
problem with you know maybe immigration
has been handled
in the north of England and if you look
at Tommy Robinson's supporters they're
desperate they are desperate they I mean
there are two videos that went on social
media recently of a group of people
chasing out what they perceived to be a
grooming gun I don't know what this was
a grooming gang or not but they they
believed it was and another one another
group driving a van into the front of a
kebab shop because they believed a
grooming gang operated from that it's
okay
these people didn't start like this they
got like this because they think they're
not being protected by the law and
they're taking into their own hands
that's bad you know we should be we
should be talking to these people with a
bit of compassion because it might well
be and I think that the Rotherham report
on the various under the 20 other cities
this has happened in shows that the
working class in the north really are
suffering and we need to take that
seriously and it's not saying that we
need to suddenly persecute Muslims or
something but we just need to accept
that these communities aren't perfect
and there's a there's a definite
cultural friction that's happening and
the police are siding with one group
over another whether that's justified or
not and it's got to be talked about
honestly but some if you look at if you
look at breaks I mean most of it there
was not clearly a new European and
European magazine where they were
essentially condemning brexit as English
exceptionalism in many ways that's true
in many ways that's true because if
there's if there's one way to describe
English political life for the last
eight hundred years since the signing of
the Magna Carta it's the word
accountability that's the English demand
it you cannot rule over this country
without being accountable and no one can
hold the Commission to account you can't
hold young John called younger to
account at all and it's it's ridiculous
to put an extra layer between the voter
and the lawmakers and and even then the
MEP aren't even the law make is they
just vote on the laws that are proposed
by the Commission so now you've got
three layers between the voter the MP
the MEP the European Council and it
keeps going I mean that is as an asthma
to English political life it's no wonder
the English well I know we just want out
we want our sovereignty back we want to
be able to hold our politicians account
we want the laws made in this country
and there's no reason that the continent
should have any savoury and I can't say
I disagree at all I voted brexit 100
percent on sovereignty and I would do so
in a heartbeat I don't care what it cost
me I don't care
really so because I've voted remain
because joking aside I'm a pragmatist
yeah I have I live in London I have a
lot of friends who small business owners
to me it's there and my dad is would
absolutely agree with you my dad married
and Latin American woman in the 1970s
when it wasn't the cool thing to do when
people were saying to him do you want
your baby to be born with curly hair all
that kind of thing and my dad went ahead
and did that and they're still together
and all the rest of it it has pretty
straight well yes because my mother's
got um Native American Indian and
they've got very straight Eggers they
related to Chinese being born but yep so
they didn't know that anyway so but he
would believe in that I could come from
it as a point of views or if it's gonna
damage our economy and it's gonna damage
it in repre bleep which is my fear then
I'm as bad as it sounds I understand
where you're coming from but
pragmatically I don't want to be in a
poorer society I don't want the economy
to suffer I don't want to be poor for my
children your children or anybody else's
do from this out in Greece well but
we're not Greece and here's the thing
and I realize that Greece is it's its
own what about Spain or Italy but what
about you still Europe you know the
European Union I think is a I don't
think it's I don't think it's what they
think it is and what they will tell you
I think it is effectively part of the
European elites plan to create a
supranational entity across Europe that
will erase national sovereignty and
create a European super-state a United
States of Europe I don't agree I
especially don't agree there it will be
effectively ruled by Germany and the
idea of the Germans ruling over Britain
is just horrendous to me the Germans are
they think in a different way to the
English the English don't trust their
institutions they don't think that
they're gonna get things right I mean do
you trust the institutions you know
exactly not exactly but a German has
faith in the Bundesbank they have faith
in the right eating the rice tightly
they have faith in their politicians and
they act differently they act in a way
that isn't in concordance with this and
that's actually to be fair and from what
I know of Jeremy the very bit that it
seems far better run and far more equal
society sure but it's a lot less free
yeah and that's the problem I have as an
Englishman I I want my freedom for
example I don't have an ID
you don't have an ID card they do in
Germany do you want an ID card no I'm
not particularly nice why not uh why not
because I would see it as controlling
but no control from the state so you
don't be run by Germany then see when it
comes down to it you know like a
pragmatic argument is an excuse not to
stand on principle it's saying well
that's gonna cost us money we may as
well just do this novel s in the world
well I think that the the way that the
European Union has gone I don't see it
getting I don't see it being reformed I
think that's being deliberately sent in
this trajectory and I think that they
probably knew it was inevitable the
British would want to leave because at
the end of the day it really does come
down to accountability and I think it's
the right thing to do even if we lose
money but even then the economic
predictions didn't come to pass you know
I don't think that they've I think
everyone's too invested in the trade
agreements to be able to say well we're
not going to trade with you that I think
they're gonna do it they're gonna do it
because they needed it because otherwise
their industry is going to collapse our
industries will collapse it's in
everyone's interest to form an agreement
the year the problem the European Union
has is I guess you would describe as
just power politics they are they're on
a very unstable base that man I mean you
see what's happening in Italy at the
moment the sort of Central European
coalition that's coming about the fact
that it's essentially Germany in France
trying to prop themselves up and then
the British and even with the second
biggest contributor to the European unit
where are they getting that money from
so reason they should be using this as a
stick to beat them with but once she's
got them in control and saying right
we're not gonna give you any money and
you're on your own we'll take the pain
but block okay okay well can we come to
an agreement and we'll say yes we can
come to an agreement we can be
reasonable but we can't let them dictate
because they will just take us for our
worth we have to be in a position to be
able to get a fair deal but we're not at
the moment because Theresa May is weak
and that's my worry is that principally
what you're saying is open could be
correct my worry is is that I look at a
lot of these conservatives and I'm like
I don't think any of you are competent I
agree and thanks my worry and what are
we actually going to leave with you
they're gonna mess it up and it's going
to be painful but in 20 years time it
will be well I bet the content doesn't
get any better I bet it doesn't get I
bet it doesn't improve one iota and in
20 years time your kids gonna like that
I'm so glad we're not living
in France right now or Spain or it's me
or Portugal yeah I'm so glad that we we
got out while we could I bet they do I
mean you gotta have some kids having
taught for 10 years and I doubt my
children would ever look at me and go I
bet you or thank you for your right my
children behave sadly but yeah it's it's
a salient point and it's also very
interesting you touched on immigration
you said open borders doesn't work what
would you propose that is what do we
need to do as a continent because we
need immigration the reality is we are
an aging population we have a deficit of
skills that we need for our NHS
engineering all the rest of it so what
is your what is your proposal okay so
the the immigration issue is an
interesting one and there there are
there are many different factors that
are playing into this so there's there's
like an iron law of wealth when a
country becomes wealthy the middle class
stops producing as many children and
this is important because then you've
got a larger number of older people in
the economy who are taking you know not
like taking pensions and taking benefits
and one on Social Security out of the
economy and there are less people paying
into it this does create a problem and
it's honestly a miscarriage from the
more selfish younger middle classes I
mean I was the same in my 20s you know I
only had a son when I was 35 you know
and so it's it's definitely a problem
that's happening but the flip side of
this is if we keep poaching the
intelligent educated people from the
third world which we do we say income
again you make lots of money and they
will especially compared to someone in
Romania or sono Bulgaria you know a
doctor there is but excuse me a doctor
there's gonna make something like $1,000
a month whereas over here they're gonna
make some like 30 or 40 thousand pounds
a year it's it's an obvious choice for
them but they were educated by their
country I mean their country nurtured
them raised them educated them you know
and it was in a public money that
provided this and we're stealing that so
in a way it's kind of like a reverse
form of colonialism we're still
exploiting these countries by taking
their talent they need these people to
improve their countries to build their
countries up into first or countries so
what point do we save right I mean we
have a moral responsibility not to take
advantage of our position of privilege
over them and so I personally would
suggest that we need to look to
educating working classes in this
country I think especially in the north
where after Thatcher decimated the coal
industry and steel industry these people
need some kind of retraining also has to
be voluntary on their part but I think
there could be government initiatives
for these on the deprived white
communities in the north that they they
need to have a leg up they need to be
said look you can be doctors technicians
or the all of the skills we need we've
got we've got stop you know building
that up because otherwise we're not
otherwise we are continually preying on
the third world countries that we're
taking people in from and with an open
borders policy like taking in the
working poor of other countries it's
that's bad for our own working poor you
know that's just creating competition it
depresses wages we they know that
they're there they're NHS the NHS is
continually under stress because 250,000
new people a year are coming here I mean
they don't pay into the system and yet
they're taking out of the system it's
not sustainable and the working class in
the north are getting furious about it
this is why you see the support the Ross
support for Tommy Robinson is scary to
me and anyone in the middle class should
be looking at that and going well we
have a problem
I mean I've met Tom Robinson I don't
think for five different occasions right
and like you know we go to it we had to
place like this identity or some other
and on the way there right I mean I was
um I was in Sussex I think I was to do
an interview for a piece of the day
Freedom Forum and we arrived at this
hotel and I saw it and I've every time
it's always the same kind of guy he's
like a shortish rough-looking
tattoos you know sort of buildings of
you know a middle a sort of guy and
spikes Tommy he looks around he walks up
and goes thanks for everything you do
mate walks off like nothing happened
happened twice and it's one elevator I
was just like holy [ __ ] you know when
people recognized me in the street using
like fans men and they're very loud and
open about it the last I love you you
know thanks very much but these people
are completely different this was grim
and serious and there is something
dangerous brewing in the north and we
need to we need to deal with them we
can't just send Owens a racist it's not
gonna make it
and it's not gonna get any better as we
saw the vigilante attacks that were
going around on social media the the
chasing out of the grooming gang the
Smashing end of the shop
yeah these people aren't gonna sit there
quietly they're not just going to allow
this continues happen to them so we have
to be very serious about immigration and
we've got to take into account the
reality of different social value
systems there's no getting around the
fact that conservative Islam is not
really compatible as a value system with
Western English values that they're just
different and they they when they hit
each other they cause real tension in
these communities and they they cause
fights they call gang wars
victimizations bullying we see this all
the time on social media because people
show it and it's I mean it's there was a
video the other day of this this guy
from you sound like you know somewhere
in the north and he was just recording
from his van of this this Muslim guy who
was basically bullying this other little
skinny white guy and he was getting to
take off his shoes he had some nice
shoes on and this guy walked up and so
know what you doing when you did he was
like even [ __ ] off Crafar or something
like that and it's like right game that
is this that is a conflict of identity
and values right he is just authorized
and he's called incur fob barbarian
effectively you know and this guy is
squaring up too and the guys just along
and put you on your ass mate if you
don't back down it's a great these
communities have to learn how to
interface but hold on hold on most of
the immigration to this country in
recent years particularly the
immigration that caused people to lead
to vote to leave if there is an element
of that it's not been from Muslim
countries not being Muslim people has
been Romanians Bulgarians that's right I
know the problems of that I mean in
Carlisle the Polish gangs like causing
trouble and smashing places up and the
sort of thing I don't disagree with you
by the way no no I'm not I'm just using
Islam as an easy example because the the
identity of Muslim is very strong and
it's a very very strong and it's it's
it's easy for a Muslim to embrace you
know now I'm not I'm not criticizing I'm
not denigrating it is just it is you
know I'm not saying it ought to be
anything it just is and it's I mean this
is I watched on or just a video that was
gone at speakers corner a while ago and
you had two groups a group of Muslims
who was chanting something Arabic
and a group of English chaps who had
chanting Rule Britannia and it was like
this you couldn't ask for a better
demonstration there's a question of
identity you know I mean there's it it
all comes down to a system of values and
we have to be able to talk about this
and we have to come to a conclusion it's
and it's the same with like you know
Eastern Europeans and the north as well
the dealer there are cultural problems I
mean it's a lot less of a problem
usually with Eastern Europeans because
normally they have a lot more in common
you know but it's we have to accept that
some cultures have values that are so
fundamentally different to our own that
they can't just be allowed to form large
what effectively parallel societies this
is something the Danes are coming to
realize and the Swedes are coming to
realise themselves except called huge
areas in their cities that just no-go
areas if you're not if you're white and
it's like we can't have that
well that's why I always say that I
think if you have immigration and you're
open to immigration what you have to be
able to do is to have a limit on
immigration such that you can integrate
people absolutely you can bring so with
immigration is a fascinating thing I'm
doing some research for an article I'm
writing on it I came to this country in
1995 right in around that time in 1997
3% of the British public thought
immigration was a major issue 3% now
it's more like 50 or 60%
oh yes and if you look at the chart for
concern about immigration on the one
hand and then immigration they're
literally the same line basically people
get more concerned about immigration as
there's more immigration because people
feel like those people can't be
integrated it's not an irrational
concern it's something that's really
affecting their lives I think but if you
say what you've just said I know I know
people in my own life who if they watch
that bit that you just talked about
Muslim identity or whatever they're
gonna say oh he's in Islam fo but I mean
what have I said this
offensive oh I mean what if I said
that's not true I know but that's the
thing is question but that's my point is
that like we live in the world now where
it's almost like you're the wrong skin
color and the wrong gender and the wrong
whatever to be talking about these
issues like if you're a woman being
critical of feminism it's much more
palatable if you were a Muslim I mean
magic now it still gets a ton of [ __ ] oh
and what he said yeah questions it of
course it is easy is
but someone like him it's more palatable
like a middle-class person watching this
interview with Majid would be like okay
we'll find he's entitled to say that he
might be completely wrong and whatever
B's entitled to say that but you're not
but doesn't it just go to show the
hegemony of far left beliefs the fact
that I'm the wrong race means I can't
talk about this I reject that completely
I think anyone of any race can talk
about any subject as long as they're as
long as they're talking from a position
of principle and they're actually
talking about factual things that are
happening I don't see why anyone of any
race can talk about any issue I mean
that's ridiculous you know and I don't
think that accusing people of prejudice
when they're actually bringing up real
things giving real examples and and
concrete reasons a logical progression
for their argument I don't see why the
accusation of prejudice seem necessary I
mean I want University in Coventry I
used to live with Muslim people I think
this was before I even knew what look I
didn't even know the word Muslim because
when I was you know twenty years old us
pretty uneducated you know and I don't
care I take people as individuals you
know I think people has their companies
so if they're if you're nice to me I'm
gonna be nice to you back regardless
what you believe because I think I think
right action is through I think more I
think moral action and morality is
through your action and intention you
know I mean if if you intend to do
something good and you mess it up then I
don't think you're an immoral person I
think you might be an incompetent person
but if you're doing something that's
right but you're doing it for malevolent
reasons you are still being malevolent
so even you know even if you're you're
doing you you know what you're doing and
you're doing it deliberately and so I
think that we should be judged on those
sorts of categories rather than just the
political beliefs of someone or the fact
that they would dare speak out of turn
because of their race or gender I mean
that to me is horrific oppressive but
there is an element to the argument
which I think partly is true which is
that as a person of a certain background
right you haven't had the lived
experience of someone else there are
certain things that you've not not
experienced in a kind of visceral way
that someone else might and when they
speak from that position it gives their
argument a little bit more like if we
were talking about Russia say right you
probably would listen a little bit more
carefully to me than to France because
she's not Russian and I would think you
would have direct experience but I mean
that just presupposes that I can't be
empathetic towards you I mean I you know
I
there's a there's a Muslim chap who
often picks me up from my house to take
me to the train station we always talk
about Islam
and I floated with him the idea today of
using the term conservative Islam versus
liberal Islam because they we need to be
able to distinguish between the mobs of
people who are marching through the
streets wearing the the folk I think
it's called and the burkas chanting
death to the West you know freedom go to
hell and the liberal Muslims who go on
the BBC and talk about how they're
progressives you know they're not the
same they don't think the same you know
that we we can't just categorize these
people in the same way and I mean he's a
very liberal Muslim you know and so I I
I think it's important that we make
these distinctions and I can empathize
with him when he's saying well I don't
like the fact that I'm being demonized
as a Muslim of course you don't
you know I don't like the idea that if I
go to if I went to Moscow I'd be
demonized for being an English hooligan
even though I'm not see I'm not a
football fan you know and so I
completely understand the problem there
and you are right you have direct
knowledge of what it's like to be in
Russia so it probably would be worth
more than your opinion but if you had an
informed opinion on something going on
that doesn't make your opinion invalid
you know and you might have a more
subjective and less actually factually
based opinion based on your own personal
lived experiences depending that unit
depends on the data depends on studies
depend almost actually happening us it's
about modeling reality accurately you
know as long as you can model reality
accurately it doesn't really matter what
you are what matters is what you're
saying is true or false I think that's
what it fundamentally comes down to is
the ability to have an actual
conversation and if people can be heard
then it doesn't matter if Francis says
something by Russia that's wrong if I
don't take offense to that and we
actually have a discussion it doesn't
matter because you we can educate yeah
exactly we can educate each other
[Music]
and the issue that the fear that I feel
and this is talking for my own personal
experience so when you're for instance
talking about Islam or what's going on
in the north number one I don't know
enough about it so I started getting
anxious number two I grew up in a pretty
racist right wing it's part of South
London yeah and for instance the pub
down my Road I used to have an Indian
flag file at all times
Asian people would get beaten up in and
around that area I used to work in a
working men's cars predominantly with
white working-class people some of whom
were lovely some of them were vile to be
honest with you and their opinions were
vile and when someone talks about that
talks and discusses ideas as you've just
done offered a sense of anxiety thinking
and what are we just seeing a regression
that is my fear are we seeing a
regression back to that sort of time
well it's interesting so I dad was in
the 70s he was a teenager and being a
mixed-race teenager he was very
obviously not white British and so and
he was one of the eldest of his five I
think six brothers I think was six of
them they had and and so my dad was
often called upon to go and fight in the
defense of one of my younger uncles who
was being bullied on racial grounds I'm
well aware I mean I grew up listening to
stories of this from from my Nana me my
dad was genuinely ashamed when my nan
told me about time that he took a plank
of wood and broke some kids arm for
being racist to my uncle my uncle Colin
and I was just proud of punch I was like
dad that's amazing he's like no no you
shouldn't do that and it's like no dad
you have to sometimes sometimes you have
to stand up to these things and I I do
understand
the the fear of that but I don't think
we can learn have to be pathological
because then when it gets to that point
we can't even have the conversation and
the conversations need to be had we have
to have this out I mean like do you ever
de convert a racist by silencing the
racist I would say no no but the
argument I would say counter-argument to
that is you never you're not dealing
with the racist what you're dealing with
is the people listening to the racist
yes see if you shut him up they then
don't hear the racist stuff they then
don't sure how they do hear you being
tyrannical they didn't hear him being
racist they heard you accusing him of
being raised
and then being tyrannical against him
and if he says well I'm not a racist
mate then you just look unjustified you
know if he hasn't even had the chance to
air these terrible beliefs then we can't
address them we can't talk him down from
it we can't talk other people watching
down from it and you look bad by doing
it you look like you're being
authoritarian and I think that that's
the the complete opposite way of the
race making someone not a racist you
know I think the only way to do is
literally talk them through their
beliefs calmly you know without
attacking them and say look they let me
hear why you think us and then I can
address the actual reasons you have and
you can only ever change someone's mind
by actually addressing what they're
saying on its own merits you know you
can't make someone different all you can
do is make them resentful and hostile
and I think that's that's honestly what
the left has been doing is a kind of
political tactic we're just going to
shut you down and now it's got to the
point where 20,000 people are on the
street because Tommy Robinson got jailed
for good reason and he shouldn't have
been interrupting the core that were
doing what he wanted to do prosecuting
the grooming gang Tommy what are you
doing you know but I'm a supporter at
song I think that normalizing this
conversation is important it has to
happen it has to you know the support
he's got you can't just sweep this under
the rug and so now we have to start
getting the representatives of these
groups and saying look talk us through
your problem you want you know you are
they actually racist they might not be
racist I mean I think I think a lot of
money I mean a lot of the members of the
EDL weren't white you know that a lot of
Sikh and black people because the Muslim
identity doesn't care about racism you
know it's actually very a racial and so
if you're not a Muslim and you're black
that doesn't mean that a gang of Muslims
won't beat you up you know they don't
give a [ __ ] you know and I'm not saying
I'm cynical all muslims but there are
Muslim gangs who do that yeah you're
energetic young men who take an identity
and it's just like the football
hooligans you know if you're not one of
us if you're not an Arsenal fan you'll
beat up an old wall fan or something
like that you know it's exactly the same
kind of psychology and process
absolutely but is that the foot my
problem is that isn't the fault of the
religion like that isn't the fault of
football nor the foot or the Football
Club the fact that some people take an
ideology to is extreme I I didn't say
that it was I know so I'm not making a
theological argument or anything
has no point I don't know I don't know I
mean atheist but I've got no interest in
trying to persuade someone that God
doesn't exist this does not something
yeah so there's no denying that there's
a conflict of like identities are
effectively representations of value
systems you know you you value something
like well it was the chap who punched a
terrorist than yon [ __ ] Millwall all
right yes what's he saying when he says
I'm Milburn what is he saying he's
saying I have a value system I believe
something you know and that matters and
it was in contrast to the terrorist
value system obviously when he was
yelling
Allah Akbar or whatever he's making a
statement of values - and it's summed up
in the identities and so it's important
that we talk about these things without
throwing allegations because that's the
only way we can find a way to synthesize
these so they can actually live in
harmony because otherwise you're
effectively creating armed camps against
one another they're always going to be
watching don't you dare say something
about my group or I'm going to get you
you know they're always going to be
doing that and we can't have that and
that's what banters for that's what
banters for you know that's why we don't
do it with the Scots in the Welsh you
know and they don't do it to us it's
because after so many years of this you
know being in contact we've realized
that if we just talk to one another we
have a bit of a laugh at each other's
expense and relax about things it's not
so bad is it you know and so you touched
on Tommy Robinson and Jude would you say
that because there's a lot of people
that we sell the racist okay he's
another racist what why would you say
he's not a racist ICCA's he's not a
racist because he doesn't he's not
concerned about the reefs of the person
he would be as opposed to a ginger
Muslim as a brown Muslim as that oh yeah
it's not as he it Tommy
you could legitimately call Tommy an
islamaphobe I think Tommy because the
thing is when people people have got
remember the bigots aren't born they're
made they're made by circumstance you
know I mean like Tommy grew up I I did I
didn't in fewer than about three years
ago because it was it was kind of edgy
and I thought oh this would be
interesting energy in it
see see if I can have a debate Tommy
Roberts let's be interesting I think you
started telling me about the things that
happened to him but how like I mean the
one that stuck stuck out to me is how I
cut I think was just one of his friends
mums
his parents though they were being
bullied by a Muslim gang on their on
their street and they you know King
bricks throw another house
but this was again and that they were
armed bats for starters although all the
young lads local lads ran down to defend
them and then the cops came and arrested
the local lads and didn't I mean these
guys the Muslim gang was standing there
with weapons and they did nothing and
it's like right cake I can see why
you're annoyed I mean his his cousin was
groomed by a grooming gang and they
there's so much social pressure and
bullying and intimidation against these
people they're desperate and they feel
the need to fight back it's it's that's
what's made Tommy what he is it's not
that he gives a [ __ ] on a race it's that
he feels that the way of life is under
threat and I don't think it's fair that
we can just say well screw you aware of
life it's not tough like you know you
don't get the protection of the law
unfortunately that's utterly unjust and
do you think the British Way of life is
underthrown I think in the north of
England it is yeah I mean they wouldn't
be doing what they're doing if it wasn't
and what particular areas if we sit
somewhere like Manchester is it in
provincial towns in Birmingham is about
to become a minority why English town do
you think the English Way of life is
going to continue there or do you think
that a more Islamic way of life is gonna
continue that and is it predominately
Islamic because there's also a large but
Caribbean community and they're pretty
they're predominantly Christians well
yeah that now that's really interesting
is it because this is this is one of the
things that the Guardian this is
something they picked up on so I did a
video called was Enoch Powell right and
I knew that was gonna be provocative on
did you my answer was no you know
there's no I can't my boy what's the law
when when in articles you know it ends
in a question mark the answers always no
you know but mance would this is a
speech I came outside to tend down
Surrey because that he wasn't right you
know black Caribbean people and black
African people integrate wonderfully
into you I mean I used to work with a
bunch of Nigerians and I'll say I
couldn't believe just how how normally
would like you know they they fit in
completely because it wasn't ideological
and that's the thing that with it with
Islam there is an ideological component
that means they have a set of axioms
that they have to build on to build
their beliefs and so I mean one of them
for the grooming gangs if if a woman is
not dressing and behaving to Islamic
standards then they're considered if
three prostitutes and so that morally
legitimizes doing something to any of
these people because then all Muslims
that they're their [ __ ] they're
disgusting it's okay to do that it
doesn't make you a bad person if you do
that that's not an attitude the black
Caribbeans old you know they're very
very easy I mean I always finding it my
wife watches EastEnders and it's very
easy to see how like you can see British
values being espoused by people of all
races on there but it's all the same
value system you know they all agree on
what right and wrong is you know and
that's that's very much the same case
with like the Sikhs Hindus like
Caribbeans black Africans it's it's the
links it's not ideological but with
Islam it does have an ideology built
within it and there are certain like
ideological aspects that come from the
feel theology of Islam honestly I don't
think that we can really address I think
they would have to the addressing that
has to come up within the Muslim
community but I think that's the reason
why Enoch Powell is wrong it's not about
their race it's about what they believe
that culture and most cultures can be
pluralistic most of them we don't have a
problem with for most of them the
Britisher remark be protective of I mean
growing up a military family
we lionize the Gurkhas my god you know
you could never say a bad thing about
Gurkha you know but I do I think that
we've got to be realistic and we've got
to look at what's happening with these
and they are becoming parallel societies
with their own legal systems their own
cultural norms and ones are often in
violation of our own moral standards and
I don't think we can pretend that's not
happening but it's also as well
everybody's own interpretation of a
religion like you said before there are
sort of liberals I know losing people
and they think they don't hold those
value systems I agree with you I think
that the problem is half lamas 46% in
mosques in this country are Deobandi
mosques and this is a fundamentalist
Pakistani ideology and it was created as
a response to the British Empire it's
the same ideology of the Taliban follow
is created in response to the British
Empire because they felt the liberal
values were actually corrupting Islam
and they wanted to return to a more sort
of fundamentalist version and this is
something that's come with the Pakistani
migration to Britain I think we need to
regulate this a lot more I don't
think we should allow fundamentalist
mosques and fundamentalist Imams
to preach hatred of gays and Jews and
the Kafar in these things and they do
not that counteract what you said
earlier about free speech though should
they not have it's not known as certain
to violence it's just an expression of
opinion like Brendan O'Neill who we had
done he's defended Imams who've preached
this stuff but you you wouldn't well
honest Aaron I think I think come I mean
in in an ideal world then sure but
unfortunate I think you've got a agree
with kind of Karl Popper on this one if
you tolerate something that is
intolerable and then the intolerable
thing will eventually consume what it
was being what was being tolerant of it
like for example I wouldn't I don't
think people should be arrest of being
neo-nazis but I think that if they're
holding neo-nazi rallies then these
things should probably be prescribed you
know they can't just allow these sort of
things to grow like a cancer and take
over a society we can't love we're gonna
lose the pluralistic tolerant values
that we are societies built on you know
we do have to be protective of that and
there's nothing wrong with saying look
if you're preaching death the Jews death
the gays death the you know death to
everyone and you're gaining of a
significant following because of your
religious authority because you have
moral authority in these communities
then maybe something should be done and
I don't like it as a free speech
absolutist I don't like it but
unfortunately sometimes we do have to
accept the pragmatic reality as we were
saying about the European Union is
sometimes you've got to pick your
battles and I realize there's an
inconsistency there but what can we do
do we just allow this to continue do we
allow they do we all have a propagation
of fundamentalist Islam in the North
middle but what can we do we've got no
choice I know so we've got no time yes
so it's been a great interview and one
of the things we tried to do
trigonometry is just bring in
interesting controversial people and
just have a conversation I think that's
great
I don't think that's fundamentally where
you are irrespective of what we agree or
disagree or and I think that's the great
thing about like someone coming from the
Soviet Union yeah that's a great thing
than most people actually don't have is
the freedom to discuss these difficult
controversial challenging ideas thank
you for coming on the question that we
always like to ask at the end this is
the one thing that you think we're not
talking about that we ought to be
talking about I think I've probably
covered in the interview yeah
I'll just finish on the gender pay gap
though that's the keep alive the deadest
horse that keeps getting up somehow it's
unfair to say it's not being talked
about okay let me women should be paid
less than men do you know why cuz they
work less hours the madmen they work
less hours than men that's that they
don't not every woman on average yeah
but the Jesus being controversal you
know where I'm absolutely right women
because the way that gender pay gaps
calculate it just an average is up all
of the total earnings of each men and
women and obviously men are go no more
because men spend more time in the
office it's crazy to think that women
can work some like 15% fewer hours than
men ended up with the same paycheck as
men that's ridiculous that can't happen
that would that would have to be done by
a system of privilege for women by
paying them more just because they're
women we can't have a society like that
you know men and women should be paid
per hour the same and then when men end
up working more hours that means they're
gonna want more money
that means the idea of the gender pay
gap is it's a just thing to exist and
you'll notice that like now younger
women are out earning younger men are we
gonna flip this we're gonna say well now
I is a man you'd start getting paid more
because women are earning more money
than me good luck it's it's exactly it's
never gonna happen and it's ridiculous
so yeah the gender pay gap is a
conversation actually needs to end well
we've had a lot of people on we had
Jonah Williams on who's worth of women
vs feminism talking about the gender pay
gap we've had actually they preach I
think one of the episodes that will come
out before this one is we had any
evolution psychologist talking about the
fact that if you poll men and women and
asked them how much do you want to work
women tend to want to work less and so
on I most people tried to put in
slightly more nuanced way than you have
but you were you're used to maybe the
reason for your success is that you're
you're keen to put things in that kind
of anyway but things there's no denying
what I've said is true you know there's
an if you put in there on average
exactly
is always calculated on average you know
that's the thing if they would say if
though it's calculated by individuals
that the the pay gap shrinks to
something like 2% it's very very minimal
and it's you know we don't even know why
that is there is an element of a
discrimination we've spoken to women on
the show who've experienced then they're
on deaf ears and usually it's about
assertiveness when it comes to pain ago
she ations and things like that but it's
not outright sexism you know these that
would be illegal and they would be able
to sue their employers and and if that
was the case why wouldn't employers just
hire women constantly it would just be
cheaper for them but some be on average
obviously when they should not be paid
the same as banks they just don't work
as many hours as men so yeah okay we're
gonna reframe it like this all people of
all genders races and backgrounds should
be paid the same per hour yeah okay and
we'll leave it there that is exactly
what I'm saying you you just you just
know how to make in the YouTube audience
sit up and get annoyed well look it's
been great having you on thank you so
much for coming on it's been absolute
pleasure before we let you go if people
want to see some of your stuff if they
want to read some of your stuff where do
they go for that oh you can you can just
google sargon and i'll be the first
thing that comes up that's a pretty
ballsy claim to make I look forward to
looks like today yeah yeah I know I know
I know it's true but I'm just thinking
like that's a really nice way to be able
to go just yet you want to find me just
put constantine in google her am i'm
right at the top that's true it's a
measure of your success is what I mean
see I'm getting banter wrong yeah all
over again
ya know I once it's been too long I've
been in this country for way too long
okay thank you very much for listening
and watching trigonometry if you liked
it please give it a rating on iTunes or
SoundCloud or follow us on youtube tell
a friend and leave us a nice review as
well that would be awesome and if
someone's a 48 Constantine I'm ad
Constantine kiss her on Twitter I'm at
failing humans so follow me there or an
Instagram to picture me looking sad in
my pants and we'll see you next week
thank you very much thanks very much
[Music]